[Applause]
[Music]
even at 50 years old Tony Hawk could
still do things on a skateboard that no
one else in the world can the Birdman
has made a career of breaking barriers
on the halfpipe so I thought it was only
fitting for one legend to judge another
set of legends in the burger world today
I'm going to cook him three
game-changing burgers and get his take
on lab-grown veggie patties a viral
internet sensation and a gourmet icon
but first let's shred
[Music]
[Applause]
had it it's too much pressure
[Music]
Tony hey thanks for having us
we're here at Tony Hawk peak in Vista
California shout out to Vista I say San
Diego but San Diego yeah yeah it's this
is amazing it just oozes everything
about you definitely my ramp um I
actually bought this building based on
the ceiling height so that I could have
somewhere to put my ramp you're a world
traveler I hear that you try to have a
burger everywhere you go what's the
craziest burger you've ever encountered
I tried one well it wasn't outside the
country but I traveled in Vegas that was
like the thousand dollar burger and they
had truffle and foie gras and caviar I'm
sure yeah it just it is not like a Tony
Hawk burger no not at all I usually just
go with cheeseburger no onions I'm a
little more careful with what I eat is
just because I'm 50 and still trying to
be a pro skater so sub McDonald's is out
of the question
no not at all you can't eat number C
knowing it's so there it is you're known
for pushing the envelope you're known
for for you know just creating new
tricks setting the standard and so I'm
gonna cook you three burgers that pretty
much shook the world kind of like you
it's awesome cool I love it okay let's
start with the impossible burger it
looks kind of like a ground meat right
I've never actually seen one raw it's
crazy because there's like flecks of fat
which is I don't know what it is and
it's made by this plant derivative heme
and it's supposed to look like me bleed
like me and this is for me a
game-changer because it's not catered
for vegetarians this is actually
marketed towards meat years mm-hmm and
it's also chef friendly chefs get behind
it people love it my only experience
with it is I have vegan friends that
swear by it
oh yeah let's cook one of these these
guys up okay you have to season this and
I wouldn't season it aggressively
because it has like such a no mommy
flavor to it very important you have to
use a nonstick pan for this yeah see
it's like very it's already falling
apart yeah we have red onions beefsteak
tomato good old iceberg lettuce
it's a sesame-seed bun' because it's
just iconic or we're almost going to
replicate the emoji I think
the provolone choice because there's
such crazy umami happening going on here
cheddar would override it so we're there
I'm gonna flip this and you see that's
the sear that I was talking about yeah
that that's what makes burgers the nooks
and crannies that's the type of stuff
like you wish you could get with a real
high quality meat because when we put
this piece of cheese on top that cheese
is gonna melt through all those Christ's
right and that to me is perfection i use
thousand ireland you know for me it's
like the california like yeah sauce the
condiment of my choice you take me to
bob's big boy that was a big outing for
us same here and then I go with pickles
because as much as I love the impossible
burger it's still very rich in umami and
you almost get like mouth fatigue so you
need this ass hits yeah I'd like to
layer it like this so that has like
airiness and crunch to it to me that's
important that the patty hangs a little
bit over the bun because I really hate
just getting a bun bite right I go
tomato iceberg lettuce here and then
throw a lid on it
that's the impossible very good possible
all-american hamburger
if you squeeze it you could see like as
if there's animal fat in there yep from
someone who eats meat pretty regularly
the meat is taste different than me
you know if the girl the ultimate goal
was to try to make it taste exactly meat
it doesn't no but it does have a good
flavor and its unique this kind of
levels the playing field all right
burger number two this is what broke the
internet it's become like the corona of
burgers you know this was served out of
like a Food Festival in New York the
same time Instagram started to get hot
before the million followers like this
was like the influential burger it's
created its own genre called the stunt
burger I could put a cheese burger that
I made on my Instagram and get like it's
a hundred likes I'll throw a ramen
burger on there and I'll get like 15,000
likes pasta its pasta as a bun yeah this
is this is actually from the ramen
burger inventor himself
yeah Kaiser shamoto salt is his meat
anything special no this is yeah this is
just regular you know 80/20 ground beef
and you kind of want to cook this at the
same time cut side down this burger is
all about texture yeah like regular
regular here
why arugula you know I think it's the
pepperiness there's a Japanese version
of this called mizuna but this is more
readily available and some scallions
but like the goodness it comes from this
sauce that he makes it's basically like
a soy sauce ginger garlic reduction of
ramen hey what do you think well I
didn't really know about this so I
thought it was just gonna be amber with
ramen noodles in there somewhere like a
sloppy joe right the things you're not
you're not just throwing it in there as
excessively right you're throwing it and
you're making it part of the actual
taste and the flavor relighting it's
cool it's so good it is weird though it
feels like you're waiting for some other
flavor right do you know I'm saying yeah
the squishiness of this yeah I don't
know what it is or your texture I don't
know it's like there's something that
you're used to and doesn't come through
but that sauce is so that sauce is
delicious yet I am surprising how much I
like it just because I thought was more
of novelty exactly with that sauce the
flavors insane you know like ollieing
over like a six step staircase with the
nest versus trying to jump a 50
staircase and not landing it and just
being outrageous but you're getting the
content that you want like what's most
what's more important that's a hard
question I think I think what's more
important is showing that you have the
skills to back up crazy attempt so for
me it's important for both you don't
want to be the guy that the only thing
that is your claim to fame is that you
tried something crazy and got hurt - you
want two people to know that you have
the skills to pack up these ridiculous
challenges
on to burger number three this is a
father's office burger it's so unique
look at the bread it's yeah football
shaped it uses dry aged meat a compote
made out of onion and bacon a mix of
Gruyere blue cheese and arugula seasoned
with salt and pepper chefs are very
snobby you know they have a pedigree
they've been around the block they've
worked for this and that and and almost
asking a chef to make a burger is
insulting
and then this guy comes out and he makes
a burger and he's like you know what I
made a burger and you can't substitute
anything you can't put ketchup on and
it's gonna be pricier and it's gonna be
pricier it's gonna be made with
ingredients that are sourced on the
highest level he shook it up then
jean-georges makes a burger Danny Boulud
makes a burger yeah well I'd say I am as
personal story about Falls office there
was such hype going into it right that
he had made this burger and the
restaurant was gonna open that I got an
invite through a friend to go to the
grand opening right and I made a point
to like go to LA just to go to this
grand opening that's nothing it was such
a scene that it actually kind of was
counterproductive because they couldn't
make any burgers for everyone so I got
basica sliver of it right yeah my god
we'll start with this crazy bun it's
like a mini baguette we'll cut this bad
boy in half is it insulting to call it a
hoagie again that's a part of the
mystique of this this this burger I
almost ate considering it consumed the
ingredients yes and while this gets
toasty we'll work on the patty you have
to do it on top of a parchment paper
because if shaped like a huggy you like
the hole and we're going beyond the two
ounce Patty and then peel it back and
obviously when you're cooking burgers
especially with delicate $50 or a pound
meat you don't want to touch it much so
we're throwing shredded Gruyere and blue
cheese it's a mixture of like a nice
mild flavor it's with a nice funky
cheese with the first burger that you
made with the red onions like not a fan
of runt onions right I definitely order
without it usually right if I were to
see blue cheese on a burger
no there's not a chance oh man I trust
you I trust him I'm gonna throw a little
lid on this just to get the cheese sand
melts on top we top it off with this
onion marmalade and then we get the
salad this is the father's office burger
google the image I nailed it that job is
wild that is insane
I don't think you can compare that to a
regular cheeseburger you just can't no
yeah this is like a meal right two
different items
I don't want a soda I don't want a
milkshake I want a nice red wine and
also this is way they pulled my piggy
out and I yeah like this is to be
savoured that is a true game changer
it's like growing up you're wearing vans
you're wearing you know a skate shoe DVS
and then next thing you know
Nike comes and makes like $150 you know
skate shoes I was like what does Nike
know about skate right yeah I mean like
we were going from like a thirty to
forty to fifty dollar shoe right well
from a from a hardcore skaters
perspective and nothing has been through
the industry for so long it's more like
why are you trying to cash in on this
but then once they put their technology
and their money into it right it did
change it for the better right and so I
totally appreciate that but in the same
way that this brought a burger into the
garment world Tony Hawk thank you for
being on the burger show I appreciate it
thank you let's get in here this is this
is momentous
[Music]
that was so close
you didn't let go
what was it me oh
double double what's up burger world's
haven't caught a lot of the burger show
smash that like button hit that
subscribe button if not for me for the
segue